hello everybody my name is markiplier
and i'm back with another round of
totally accurate battle simulator mostly
just because there's a lot of stuff oh
there's more levels actually oh
cool
spooky
spooky one spooky two spooky one
i like spooky spooky's real fun
spooky's really fun but there's no need
for this to be ah maybe we'll keep it
spooky i kind of like it'll be a little
spooky
nothing wrong with a little oh wait this
is exactly the same map that i had
before
damn it we gotta go spooky too on this
also there's custom content units
i can make a new unit wait whoa wait a
minute whoa turn off the spooky i can
make a new unit
base is a stiffy
a halfling okay halfling gotta be the
halfling okay weapons okay two-handed
whoa
okay explosive death definitely that's a
number one okay he's got freaking
amazing
dodge
he's got the super boxer punch you know
it baby and then he's got
just the s
the
hurricane slash
and uh god like projectile block
god like dark biscuits
is the dark peasants i love this oh he's
gotta have the minotaur charge oh you
know he's got that all right let's test
him out
whoa
my guy my guy my god oh my god let's
give him some clothes
head you know it okay torso you know it
okay
legs
um
you know it um feet
uh
you know it stats okay we're gonna give
them just
this guy's a [ __ ] god and he's we're
gonna make him the smallest the largest
halfling
how big
how big can you go he's too big okay
that he's he's he's freaking huge and
trembling
okay unit weight
very heavy
way too fast attack speed is
astronomical
damage is undeniable uh let's test them
out
oh my what is that what are you
oh my god
i think he's limited by his tiny boxing
glove i don't know why it's so tiny
you know i think i think we uh i think
we uh lost the plot a little bit by
making him
a giant i think he needs to stay
halfling or else you know it it don't it
won't make sense
oh man
undeniable
undeniable oh undeniable
[Music]
okay anyway let's uh let's let's get out
of here oh this is what we're here for
we're here to try out some of these uh
other things that i have not had a
chance to try yet let's do spooky two
and keep it nice and spooky in here oh
yeah this is better so where were we
snake archer what is this supposed to be
besides the obvious
i mean
hi guys
i don't know what i was expecting go
fire your snakes oh they keep going
oh
all right so that wasn't nearly as
exciting as i thought it'd be
zeus all right
it's okay
all right well that makes sense red zeus
is getting his ass kicked damn here
comes
bam
all right whatever
boring we need to get out of here we
need to get to the good stuff head
butters
head butters
[Music]
you're doing great guys oh
nice
okay but not really why we're here and
we need to get kind of going
on the intensity here where did you go
hello
whoa did you see that dodge holy crap
damn these oh never mind they're dead
all right boring let's get these guys
out of here what i need to see let's get
this spooky out i can't see anything
monkey king dragon
oh
that's not a real giant
uh-huh
okay
all right i'm getting out of the spooky
all right let's do
painter
[Music]
god damn get out of here get out of here
balloon archer
okay
i'm ready
nice almost you almost had it
and you didn't know okay you could
actually hit your target
any day now
[Music]
uh okay
oh
well that was less fun more deadly i
like it though all right come on this is
get we need some more here
what happened
okay
god it's so quick
oh
[Music]
oh my god
sorry that was just very funny for some
reason i have no idea why
ah wow those are amazing
okay well good luck fighting each other
i don't even know if they're gonna
penetrate the armor
oh you gotta hit the dude inside
well that's gonna be a little oh never
mind all right clear them renaissance
boring blunderbuss
i like the sound of that
holy [ __ ] are you okay you had a barrel
all right any day now
it's not
[Music]
goddamn i thought he was down
freaking [ __ ]
every time you think you got it
are they doing anything oh
finally
damn okay good that was
i mean that was pretty incredible all
right let's go with this guy
uh well that was much more impactful oh
they're not dead well don't get in the
way of again
okay
jesus
all right watch out buddy
okay cannon's a little overpowered how
about a captain versus a pirate queen
no
cheap shot stab
good slash across the buttocks oh i
tried to go for a shot but couldn't
quite tell the difference between pirate
queen of the ground wow
spinning uh ninja kick right to the
groin
since the cabin tumbling but also very
boring okay what about spooky oh
candlehead
love it
oh
okay
i'm not sure what you're doing
what did you do
ectoplasmic goo i don't know sword
caster
sword cast
oh my god
oh my god it's incredible
wow
oh double kill oh pumpkin catapult ooh
that's pretty fun
[Laughter]
i'm sorry that was amazing all right
wild west dot cactus yep
all right good enough
minor
dynamite thrower
gun slinger
last year
dead eye
quick
draw they're taken care of
oh
who
did that to them
what did you just say to me
oh
get him
get him get him
oh you got him let's see good
devout gauntlet
what what happened i missed it i blunked
damn nice my dude divine arbiter
sacred
chrono answer
oh my god you okay there
oh what are you doing
what did you just do
that's less hilarious and more just bad
ass
oh god damn nice shot
okay good well that was nice very well
done evil shadow anchor exiled sentinel
mad mechanic
void cultist tempest lich death bringer
and void monarch
damn
damn that's cool secret how do you
unlock the secret characters more
factions whoa
interesting okay how do you unlock the
secret characters that's what i want to
know
okay so what i need to do is apparently
to unlock the secret characters you have
to go to the map that has
the weapon that they use and then you
need to look at it for like five seconds
or something so
dude man uh here you you just
duke it out for a bit i need to go look
at a tree because apparently there's a
tree here that is specific or something
like that oh what about this
[Laughter]
boom
oh executioner oh that's cool oh oh
that's the treat
bam
yes that's exactly what i was hoping for
okay but now you guys are boned because
i'm gonna throw some freaking tree
giants at you okay so the scenario is
the tree giants
were really sick
of uh all these stupid humies
coming in
and uh stealing all their trees
basically
where's someone with an axe well i guess
the executioner no no no peasants
[Music]
okay i'm thinking numbers must mean
something here that's a lot of numbers
never mind they are all dead now
my god
i got oh my god
hold on have mercy
have mercy
have mercy please
[Music]
oops um oh
hey smart
very smart they'll never get you there
oh you're gonna be totally fine
no all right so that that didn't go so
good for them what they need
is
many guns
see giants are no match for guns
we all know this oh take our weaponry
oh take them
no match for guns
you stupid giants
never stood a chance this'll do it all
right let's do it
oh they really can do nothing when it
comes to distance and closing that they
can do nothing all right i'm gonna do
something nutso
we're gonna pit an epic battle of good
versus evil
all right now the evil
shadow walker exiled sentinel
mad mechanic deathbringer
okay
epic battle between good and evil place
your bets on who's gonna win at this
point
gu
oh hell yeah
mom
[Music]
i think good drown stevil i think good
trounced them not by a huge margin but
uh for those of you who bet the good was
gonna win congratulations you sure did
it let's give some more uh void monarchs
to see if this evens it out
damn
[Music]
oh my god
this is actually amazing you know when i
first played this game many years ago i
was like ah man this game is always just
gonna be dopey goofy fun this is
freaking awesome
this is amazing
this is incredible this is actually a
battle simulator they somehow
accidentally made a real battle
simulator out of this
okay it's down to the final few forces
this is one dude versus that dude
oh oh you alright bud oh not so good
oh god oh god you got turned into a
golden skeleton oh
there's still a couple left
oh
never mind you're dead evil kind of
blows
it's that nuke from the paladins right
right off the get-go they just blast
them and then once uh once these guys go
super saiyan it's kind of game over so i
don't know what's going on with the uh
the
the mega units for the other team but
man they are not pulling their weight
that's dope as hell though that is
amazing that is incredible
what kind of like uh what kind of um
custom
things have been pre-made for some of
these because i got campaigns here
oh right i could actually play i forgot
i could actually play this game
and try to beat it in situations that
actually demon
alright the tree tribe i guess so i have
3 000 right do i have to i feel like
it's only fair if i match them in terms
of their
uh skill level so i'm just gonna
spam spear throwers because i feel like
it's tactically better go my dudes kick
their ass
they'll never get close to you
oh well that's a problem you guys going
to get your spears back or uh what so
what's that what's that what's the deal
here
okay good good uh you might want to
throw faster you might want to throw
faster you might want to throw faster
okay good you might want to throw faster
okay good you might want to throw you
might want to throw
oh
oh that was unfair that was incredibly
unfair who's over here
you alive
you playing
he's playing dead okay
my guy i don't think it's working oh
okay so there's a whole plethora of ooh
of actual things that you could do hey
look it's just a bunch of farmers
well looks like they get the halfling
rush they're never gonna stand a chance
they're never gonna know what hit them
the halflings are coming
and you
forgot that they're basically children
but it seems to be working i think i'm
winning
i honestly think i'm winning maybe not
maybe not maybe not maybe so maybe so
maybe so get them grab their faces keep
them in the balls
oh
oh my god it's down to the wire it's
actually down to the last man
with a kidney shot a liver shot whatever
shot that is well done well done my dude
anyway that is all for this episode i
really don't have much time for any more
so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to see more of this
oh my god what is that
what is that if you want to see more of
this let me know down in the comments
below you can play this game for
yourself link is in the description and
if you get it remember
i have a creator code
m-a-r-k-i-p-l-i-e-yar
you can try for yourself on the epic
game store alright thank you and as
always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
oh